all right so this one Rob doesn't even
know what we're doing cuz I was coming
in I was like hey what's up your ëismí
is it just surprised me surprised me so
uh okay we're doing the Power Ranger
movies fuck yeah
cuz you know there's so much to talk
about with them but actually what I kind
of want to get to also is just like our
take on Power Rangers in general um
because it's kind of funny because we
were too old just at the age where I was
heavily jewelry if you were on the cusp
yeah but it was right in between like
x-men and Batman like they played Power
Rangers in between x-men Batman which is
like how dare you but it's one of those
things where it's like I get it it is
kind of like our Ninja Turtles it's
obviously stupid and the fans know it's
stupid but it's so enjoyably stupid and
their childhood if there is oh I'm not
gonna knock anybody who grew up with
yeah I mean it's not something it's not
like we had Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
I mean the original run yeah and that's
pretty silly pretty fucking goofy um so
it's kind of the same thing where it's
like watching it I mean you know you
could be like oh file exam but it's like
and deflect that noise I mean it oh it's
everywhere
it survived ninja inge yeah Samara
apparently in Europe it's Teenage Mutant
Ninja hero turtles because of me I don't
know
juror I've heard the German version of
the song and they say here as well so I
don't know if they have similar rules
when the UK apparently ninja Inga's been
outlawed they're apparently somewhere in
the UK's history they had this ninja
outbreak yeah we got a bit we're gonna
put a stop to this because people are
getting assassinated by ninjas left
because I don't know if it's still true
what last time I was there I was asking
about and they were saying like yeah I
think that change I'm not a hundred
percent oh man but I just oh it seems
like a silly thing now how do you bring
that up in Parliament I'd love to see
that discuss in the House of Lords in
the next motion the uproar of ninja
mom that's a bridge in prison a show
British Parliament at least oh the wrong
guy recognizes the totem in the corner I
think it should be allowed we are our
rubber rubber up
you didn't say doodoo that's why we're
saying new um doing this out loud - oh
he just insulted an entire culture we're
so good at that
um okay so when the show first came on I
think especially because x-men and
Batman were on and they were just like
really for even though they could get
silly - they were mostly really trying
to take their younger audience seriously
here cuz Power Rangers that we were kind
of excited
Oh looks kinda takes it seriously if
you're six I could see a six-year-old
watching that completely engrossed but
so we turned this on and we see the
first episode in like five minutes in
were like this shit - like this
inaudible and we were like they were
they were plugging it like yeah see Fox
was like it's far as good at plugging
there yeah as far as Fox was concerned
if you had to only see one show this
entire century it's going to be bloody
Morphin Power Rangers so they replaced
that way if you hear one song the ideal
cage the theme song is amazing
um but I always say uh I forget what
question always spawns it but I tell
this story all the time of cons about
how you know I think they ask is their
show that everyone else is into bed that
you guys aren't and I was bring up our
Inge's I was talking about how we
watched the first episode looked at each
other and more like uh-uh this is going
no I'm never gonna get some shit I mean
you later who the hell would watch this
piece of crap and it's still going on
and this is why I will never ever invest
in the stock market
cuz relearned biggest wrong haha yeah um
so I always observe is like hungry did
not like power juice I was like to be
fair it really proved us very very
hilariously wrong yeah it really showed
how bad we are and predicting what's
going to be a hit I think like yeah and
half my friends were like somewhere into
it some were not but even the ones life
in bed
we're watching it cuz it was kind of fun
to just sort of make fun of it right
around 12 I think when it came out I was
like I was very cynical - yeah I I was
like 14 and I'm just like this I where's
that this is meant for little kids when
little kids so and I was a very cynical
fourteen-year-old and I'm like I'm
wondering that shit like yeah area goes
to that jerk high school phase like
truck yeah driving tunes fuck that noise
and above that then Batman the Animated
Series came out I'm like well I guess
I'm gonna be watching cartoons through
high school but um so yeah so the show
comes out we don't think module we just
know everybody's talking about and like
well these little kids I should say and
it's a huge hit it was like that was the
toy that year that everyone had to get
uh you know it was a big big deal so
this so the movie comes out of the first
movie and I didn't see it on the big
screen um why would we oh you know no I
remember because I was talking with some
friends and we were kind of making the
argument that maybe it was going to be
like the Ninja Turtle movie where it was
like yes kind of goofy but it is more
adult no no I need to do something yeah
I use like the trailer did yeah what'll
be really for the Turtles movie look
dark and gritty the memories but just a
little darker no a little darker more
nighttime you know like Power Rangers oh
so there were more nighttime shots of
course it didn't show anything about the
story or anything like that was just
insane you know tubular awesome gotta
love it like that's it uh you know you
knew nothing else about the movie oh the
trebles movie compared to the cartoon
that looked like daredevil or dead no
that looked like Game of Thrones
compared to the rankin/bass Hobbit I
mean it was so it was such a huge
difference the Power Ranger movie
trailer I'm like I'm just okay it just
looks like the Power Rangers like if
there was no really it looks like no the
fight thing is at the time it looks like
they up there a little bit but then we
saw like a spongy no we saw the CG and
we're like you know that looks wrong but
I don't know why yeah we're not used to
yet to realize why it doesn't look right
and now yours later watching it again
it's it is garbage CG I mean it is like
insultingly Bad Seed
even for the entire period and its power
yeah no no no no to Power Rangers credit
I'm even though it's in Japan so they
got in the cartoons they use the models
that they built that stuff and like I
said I'm having much more an
appreciation even though it looks fake
there's an appreciation okay okay I see
what you're saying
cuz I was gonna say at least in the
Japanese version and there's a charm to
its low-budget quality and by trying to
up it with CGI and stuff you lose that
charm it's like for me at least on a
goofy level Power Rangers is fun to
watch for the models for the guys in
costumes
franki a guy for the cheapness of a
cheap CGI has no charm yes zero nothing
to them what what I found out when we
saw the nerd movie I forgot how like an
even though they're CG in that too uh
you notice how SIA models I don't open
that can of worms yes yeah but the big
thing is that you know even though it's
obviously people in costumes and the
obviously models and stuff like that I
forgot how appreciative I was when I saw
impact like real impact even though it's
fake and I appreciate it much more even
though it totally tears roomy SI ya
wasn't really hitting it you feel the
impact and you when you see what CG it's
like you're watching nothing uh now it's
like sometimes they can do it well and
sometimes it can be really creative but
there's a library stuff but you do well
it can be really impressed yeah why not
you look a bad cartoon yeah even
cartoons can sometimes fake it better
than what CG is doing could you feel the
impact more and I think it's kind of
same thing with the Power Rangers when
you are seeing these to fight yet we
know they're not giant monsters but at
least you know there's impact happening
where when you watch with CG you know
they're not giant monsters and you know
there's no impact happening so at least
you can say that and with the first
movie that's not even there they don't
even have the models or the people Inc I
know poor Hikari wannabe or whoever is
in the suit you know in Japan is at
least suffering for his um so yeah and
with the to film I will say this because
I was watching the second one when we
reviewed the second one I was saying
well will this
be better or worse or whatever is that
how do you really compare it to the
person oh you funnier I see for me it's
hard to say which one I liked or
disliked the the more be because with
the first one in a strange way even
though it made no sense it still kind of
felt like a film accountable Tyco a film
the second one just look kind of like a
longer bizarre episode but at the same
time they still had the models they
really had the people in the new giant
machines in stuff even though that
wasn't much of it uh so it's like I'm
really sort of torn on the two and the
first one worked a little bit more like
a movie - the second one you know is
much more like a b-movie like you know
from like again like you guys know the
movie etc movies but at the same time I
can respect that - right right down to
the like Japanese obsession with some
little boy who happens to have some
ancient knowledge through magical powers
or for some reason all government
officials and superhero teams are like
you're a small child come fight with me
for reasons um that's what always kill
me about the Godzilla and the gamourai
movies Gamera in particular that was a
gamera vs. GUI run that one of them had
this boy who was just obsessed with
traffic accident and then a dumb so
horribly it was a great mystery science
in Episode I always just remember this
this kid who gets like there's some
alien plot and he gets wrapped up in
this I'm like what are these two
children doing here but always like I
want to live in a world without stealing
Oh traffic accidents and like that's all
you know without war or crime or traffic
accidents like or stealing
it's like apparently stealing and
traffic accidents shame your ancestors
something fierce over here it was this
very bizarre you should check it out
it's really hilarious but it but right
down to that because they had the was it
the Blue Ranger the K yeah the blue kid
who who hilariously well like yeah who
is like gotta be two feet tall but that
suit has magical powers apparently gives
you like 40 inch heels or something
because he grows like a good two feet
whenever he's in the suit from from what
I heard uh the kid that was brought in
for that in the Japanese version
there was no little kid they were all
still teenagers I'm sure they switched
him out constantly because they have to
grow up but they would uh you know they
still use teenagers and then here they
were like well we need to bring in the
younger demographic cuz hey kids love
imagining they're teenagers but you know
we need a little kid in there to to be
like hey you can be a batter so we get
the best of both work with what hire a
little kid money's in the city turns
into a teenager yeah exactly it's both
it's idiotic Lee brilliant I see I am of
the opinion small children just don't
belong in most movies most movies could
do with if it's anything that all of
their rebel backers over the years have
taught us it's just just don't do it one
every once in a while you'll find a
Haley Joel Osment you know you'll find
an early Macaulay Culkin who can pull up
but for the most part they they're just
not any good so just just if you're
thinking of putting children in your
movie don't do what is as we said before
uh it's not really their fault they're
kids
oh no I got a jiffy I'm not whining I'm
not blaming the kids but like are the
best it you know what they did in they
oh they blew rangers mm did it's like
The Blues Brothers where they brought
that damn kid in the everyone that's why
when we were watching it that's how I
feel like I felt like I was watching
Blues Brothers 2000 like oh my god I met
you shocked they didn't grow them up in
them but we all knew our shit that
happened did this come out around the
same time like that early 2000s like I
thought it was before blues burstered
that could be wrong I don't know I feel
like the late like post-2000 early 2000s
this was a thing we have bezouro sequel
do it The Mummy sequel do we have Blues
Brothers 2000 that I don't know when
this film was released god knows what it
was the original footage was released
look into trying to come back at it did
that nobody was buying wiping they
always way through that we need a small
child in our movie for something like I
hate that
ya know what B so rarely make them go
they so really good good performer to do
it um but uh yeah but again with like
we're talking about like animatronics
and cell there's so much better than CG
and stuff and then you get those hideous
willow Munchie things whatever those
were in the second one they thought what
I just totally remember the gusting I
it's like the first a no track you see
in this in the planet that's all green
they just add a green filter that's it
seriously
the fuck you just see this thing that
wars were freakish it looks like it you
know even by garbage kid Stan Garbage
Pail Kids standards he was pretty ugly
looking it just look like this the whole
time and there's supposed to be a call
he's cute I remember at the end they
brought a couple of the other Ranger in
the sequel they brought a couple of the
other Rangers back and the hiatus didn't
improve their acting out that's right a
I'm sure um a little over Kimberly and
no not Rocky the I can remember the
other one Adam one of the red Rangers I
think oh the only one I ever know is
Kimberly and Tommy I don't know any of
them like those are my name's I remember
only one both films and there's
something about it um the only one I
believe somehow I don't know whether
Izzy's giving it his all but I just I
just believe in his performance is uh
the one the only the amazing the boss
you're just saying that cuz we see him
at so many kinds no actually I honestly
I think he's the only one that like gets
at it and it's hilarious because he has
no dignity in those movies then for some
reason they always shut out in most
movies hate this guy this character in
the first one that in the first one he
like he's the Frog and then it's like
but the princes kissed the Frog it is
like I'm like wow that blows and the
second one they get all of these
kick-ass vehicles and he could get a
mini got the fucking soccer-mom minivan
like he's driving his kids to the game
after school and I'm like riffing he's
got that stupid David from Roseanne
haircut um beautiful let's just imagine
oh really - they're crouched I think of
any of them that was like that's like a
bad bad actor Ann thing I'm like I think
they're just doing Thursday by selling
it I mean they're just doing it's always
a mid lane he's the only that for some
reason whenever I watch it I'm like I
Chi and not say that I'm not going to
disk Johnny and Bosch's acting because
he's certainly a great voice actor
that's for damn sure but
I'm not saying it's like a great
performance like this is amazing but out
of that whole set he's the only one that
for some it may be it's because his
character gets shit on so he always kind
of looks like he's the only one I kind
of believe like out of all of them well
it's certainly not the bullies yeah I
know the bullet the boys are with Judy
really bad but I'm sure they weren't all
that bad at me don't be certainly was it
yours only wasn't that kid and in the
sequel so he's for some reason he's the
only one that I I don't know if he cared
so much in his performance I don't know
if he didn't maybe he didn't care at all
maybe he's just like you know whatever
I'm driving a minivan and then like
because of that frustration it comes out
but no I mean with only one honestly
with them like I said I think they're
all about the same plane of hey we're
gonna do it it's popular if for kids
what ends you know they all can have
that feel but it's not like insultingly
like yeah we don't care fuck it I mean
yeah just enough but like you know it's
like they're trying to find the middle
ground we know this is stupid but we
still want even little kids to kinda
take it seriously so like whenever it's
like whenever the actors talk about
Saved by the Bell
like they just knew this was silly yeah
I mean good morning miss bliss at least
was like a Disney show you may be trying
to figure that out a bit where the tones
gonna fit but by the time you get into
the latter half of season one or season
two is Saved by the Bell like they knew
they're like you know when they talk
about the episode so like this is
ridiculous she's overdosing on nodos
look at caffeine pills like they knew
how ridiculous it was except for maybe
Dustin Diamond who I think never left um
but no be definitely left out a long
time ago um but uh yes I mean in terms
of the two films do you have one that's
like oh this one's better this one's
worse is her IV like they're both bad
for kind of different reasons just i up
i never thought i'd say it's objectively
speaking I think the first film is
better if I'm going by which one I found
kind of funnier just because it was so
beyond batshit crazy
probably the sequel just because like
every single decision you could
is wrong like every single thing they do
except we're wrong wrong got that sir
yeah like laughter then when we missed
it why just wrong
like is wrong even the even Zordon the
first one they upped him a bit
you mean they upped him a bit and
actually got like a real person whose
mouth matched what he was saying okay
yeah you know I never thought I would
say this but on the totem pole that is
the Power Rangers this in not knowing
anything about the Power Rangers really
go to go to Linkara for that um the
second one feels like a cheap corporate
shield to me whereas the first one by
comparison does not the fun felt like
they were trying to do like okay we have
this show let's make a movie an actual
movie on it and it won't be good it
won't make sense but it's a movie at
least it felt like it was at least
trying to do right I guess like I'm
talking as somebody who doesn't have
jack shit about Power Rangers but the
vibe I got from it was that they were
trying to do right by the Power Rangers
by the Power Rangers fans and then by
the very low bar Power Rangers set they
were trying to do right by it so the
second one it felt like they lowered the
bar way further you know what it felt
like - it felt like there was even
though god help me if I know what it is
if they were shooting it like there was
an arc even though there is and that's
the big thing that we complain about but
they're showing like the emotions go
through the arc of hey we're having fun
we get along now something has happened
you know a friend is dying I never
realized how much I appreciate him I
guess that's the art that it's like we
appreciate sorta he was like a father to
us even though we have no idea how he
puts him in danger constantly he kidnaps
them they were you know puts him up
against this evil mastermind our kind of
mastermind they were trying to tell a
story or at least they thought they were
and there was the thought that they're
gonna try to tell she's on the truth at
least she think she is
yeah um yeah but it's the cyclin I'm not
even sure the writers were like I don't
know III just got this very big feeling
of fucking it's like adds Power Rangers
fuck that yeah like what do we got just
happen throw it in there Oh a pirate
ship uh that I make no sense
I'm like something for making these cars
that they drive to a pirate ship hi
something I just remembered that that
was one of my big criticisms we're
watching and I'm like sweet you just
give these people these awesome kick-ass
vehicles and then all they do is just
drive to a pirate ship what fucking
sense does ending I mean maybe if the
pirate ship turned into a transformer
and flew or something like but I feel
like is it seamen big it's like it just
turns into a building like literature
giant bug like it but that's how I'm
thinking I'm thinking like a
ten-year-old watching this I'd be like
me and even is it a no I'd be kind of
disappointed I don't assume an episode
you want to see that shit in action so
yeah but I said we got a you know the
the climax with the the giant robots and
stuff like you know that's got cool
cthis Power Rangers that's only part
where I feel like okay this haven't put
the second one still feels like just
kind of a long weird episode from what
I've seen of the show or it feels like a
couple episodes like strung together but
that's why it doesn't feel like a movie
and it's like when you're gonna do a
movie make a movie like actually you
know do what you can do is always like
the next generation to Star Trek next
generation problem make a movie not just
a long episode yeah good movies made it
feel like a movie the damn buoys you
felt like you're watching a long episode
with a few better special effects so
that's it it's hard to say which one
feels more like you know the sphere of
the Power Rangers because it's like one
is corny and silly and most of the stuff
is really there but it's like even watch
the show for that we're the other one
you know made some big errors by having
the CG and stuff but it also felt like
hey we're gonna try it all matter is
this for you because it's a movie you
deserve you're paying money to see the
sequel or at least mom and dad are and
if you're gonna do that you should at
least try to put together a coherent
movie doesn't have to be perfect but I
think something that would satisfy Power
Rangers fans I just got this impression
that this wouldn't satisfy her maybe I'm
wrong maybe almost something we're gonna
come out of what are you kidding a
sequel is amazing it's wicked is either
really yeah um but I felt like if I were
a kid watching it it wouldn't have
impressed me after the first movie I
would have been like what what the hell
yeah at least if I was like you're
watching it I saw the first film even
though the CG looks like shit and we
to a bank then we also can do like this
is big and this is kind of new at the
time that kind of CG and at least it's
like okay they're trying something
different they're trying something to up
the ante even though a they backfired
uh yeah we're with the second one I mean
I can watch this on TV yeah I I can just
watch a couple episodes like it can't
the same idea um but I don't know I feel
the funniest thing about Power Rangers
altogether is the stuff I like most is
the the cheesy fights with the guys in
the silly fish suits and the the giant
robots of the mega sword no you know I
because of my love of like old Japanese
that I that I love like it's whenever
they cut to the kids in school or the
teenagers or whatever the plot is
outside of the fights I'm like wait yeah
it's pretty good one and that's kind of
on say about their acting before cuz
even if they were really really bad
actors it would probably be more
enjoyable ah because you would see like
if they were all acting like bulk and
skull LMR I'm not gonna name names but
there's a couple in that group that I'm
like wow um but you're right they're not
they're not like that bad yeah I
remember being like passable like I said
they'd answer it so there were a couple
that stuck out them like wow this is
pretty bad The Hulk it was me Oh boss
the little carrot so two plus one yeah
that's three um but uh yeah so there you
go I mean like I said we kind of didn't
grow up the Power Rangers where we grew
up with it just the wrong time uh
but any people that like and obsess over
and stuff like that not gonna be like
you know what's wrong with you we have
internal that's real art it's like no
it's I get it it's silly it's dumb it's
enjoyable it's not really hurtful or
offensive or anything like that I mean
some people I love it the go and love it
embrace it totally enjoy it uh we just
got in there too late
I mean hating Power Rangers is saying
like oh hey like The Flintstones or
something well if you started watching
it after the age of twelve year the
wrong age group yeah um so I I don't
hate Power Rangers I just yeah not I
think I don't like Flintstones
you know I know it's harmless it's just
it's another one of those that just
helps me in all the wrong areas
I don't do just don't like it god they
take the innocent animals force them to
do that's the only funny face that's the
only funny thing it's like okay I just
might say what the sinks gonna make them
slowly dying while chewing on Fred's
garbage or earth it's a living yeah yeah
I it's like it's it's fine there's
nothing wrong with it it's just not I
don't know the Great Gazoo dum-dum oh I
fucking eat it out okay
yeah the angle rock Vegas sometime I
know what I'm gonna get you for
Christmas
beemo rock Vegas no no the original
cartoon oh you even better okay
you can't get me the Seth MacFarlane we
done what which I'm sure was even better
or did that ever go through they're
saying they were gonna but it didn't
send MacFarlane say he was gonna redo
the Flintstones or something I I thought
like years ago it it never went through
why I don't know who did it was called
Family Guy assisted ready headed again
with the cleavage slow and American dad
honestly this shit but honestly the
Flintstones was done again by the
Simpson like all of that owes itself to
the Flintstone no I guess that's why
it's like I know it's not like bad awful
I just never liked it oh but I wink I
don't know they did do that it was a
that uh cape guy show the the Geico
caveman a Geico caveman show okay well
we know what to hit that was uh so yeah
that's about it
I'm making that up don't correct me on
because I know that I know what's on
actually take that you know what you
never know someone will I always get I
get to anything I use is a joke
there's always I get one comment or
somebody sends me there's always some in
someone else and so yeah if you will
under set higher I am finally
comprehending this wait so I not human a
human concept what's that guy from our
guardians of the galaxy is just like you
know nothing goes over my head oh yeah
it's like there are just some people
there that he takes everything litter
so when that said we will see on the
next one later